[Music]
okay i'm well okay what is the
difference if someone is baptized in the
name of jesus or baptized in the name of
the father and of the son and of the
holy ghost
now jesus said baptized name of the
father the son the holy ghost that's
what jesus said
now the bible has degrees let me take
time on this what do i mean by the bible
has degrees who is the most powerful
angel in heaven gabriel he has more
power than any other angel
jesus had 12 disciples
three of them were close to him in the
other nine on several occasions he take
the three peter james and john not do
the other nine because those three were
closer to him of those three john was
the closest and so he gave his mother to
john john chapter 19 26 27 when christ
was on the cross there are degrees
israel was closer to god than any other
nation the high priest could go where
the levite couldn't go degrees of
responsibility and privilege now
given that question again
what is the difference between being
baptized in the name of jesus did that
right right now jesus said
baptized in the name of the father the
son of the holy ghost who in the bible
has more authority than jesus
is it paul
is it timothy someone explained that to
me who understands truth better than
jesus
christ when he was on the earth was man
he was still god
so when he said baptize the name of the
father the son holy god what is my
justification for leaving that and go
say well paul said
when it was paul who when was christ who
called paul to preach the gospel now
i'll tell you something else
if you study the destruction of sodom
and gomorrah people only think of sodom
and gomorrah let's go to the book of
jude let's read verse six
jude verse six my first seven of the
book of jude verse seven of jude let me
show you something the book of jude
verse 7
let me know when you have it so we can
read it
okay
what does that say even as
even as sodom and gomorrah
[Music]
giving themselves over the fornication
and going after strange flesh in in
other words solomon gomorrah are the
cities we use to express immorality but
the first since the other cities in
like manner but why does every bible
writer have to write
sonam gemara admiral zaboy mandela let's
go find out what the cities were let's
go to genesis chapter 14.
i'm really glad for this question
because i've heard this before
genesis 14 we read from verse one
okay
you have it
yes i do and it came to pass in the days
of uh amrita king of china ariel king of
alessa kendall aroma king of elam and
title king of nations those of the
invading army that these made war with
bera king of sodom and with bursa king
of gomorrah china of king of admiral
shamivah king of the boy and the king of
baylor so we have admirals the boy
baylor solomon tomorrow we have five
cities
those were the cities of the plane but
the bible almost always just says sodom
and gomorrah but when we reach solomon
tomorrow we must also understand admiral
andela but there is no need to write all
when jesus told the rich young ruler in
luke 18 he said what must i do to
enhance eternal life jesus said thou
knows the commandments don't commit
adultery but he does not quote him
why quarrel 10 just a few will tell you
he's referring to the ten commandments i
hope i'm getting through on this now we
know of the rebellion of korra death and
a pirate
they rebelled against more we know that
yes but if you read um
i think is psalm 1 or
i think it's 106 verse 17. go there for
me make sure i'm right psalm 106 verse
17.
okay
the earth
106 verse 17.
the earth opened and swallowed up
staffing
and covered the company of aberrant
who's left off
there are three core ideas in another
room
but korra isn't mentioned but
he is to be understood as part of that
group now let's go to the book of jude
read verse 11 the book of jude
and ran greedily after the era of balaam
for reward
and perished in the game
now when paul says the baptized name of
jesus we must understand father and holy
spirit as well
but there's no need to keep mention all
the time but the fundamental principle
is jesus said father son holy ghost no
one has more authority than jesus christ
if your father tells you do this and
then your little brother who's five
years old tells you do something else to
whom do you listen are you following me
who has most authority in the bible
jesus
he said father son holy ghost why are
you bringing up you know what paul said
yeah i understand paul is inspired but
jesus himself is truth
paul himself isn't true
jesus is truth
he said father son of holy god
i don't sorry for getting all worked and
doctors but some some things really get
my goat no well no not my god something
else they really irritate me and i have
to restrain myself there is no more
authoritative person than jesus
and he said father son holy ghost
why are you telling me that you know
paul citizen paul said that yes god
bless paul but paul got it paul was
called by jesus christ
this jesus said father son holy ghost
that's how you baptize
let me calm down maybe no more questions
because i may just lose my mind
amen yes
father have mercy on me
some things just get my goat they really
do
you